[موسيقى]
ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء يا عنزتي يا عنزتي
ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ما احلاكي ما احلاكي
ما ما ما ما ما يا عنزتي يا عنزتي ما ما
ما ما ما ما احلاك ما احلاك ماء ماء ماء
ماء ماء في المزرعه ماء ماء تاكل عشبا
تشرب ماء ما ماء ما ماء ما ماء ما ما من
ردد في المرع ماء ما ماء ماء ماء ما ماء
ماء ما من ردد في المرعى ما ذات صباح ماء
ما جاء الثعلب ما ما رتب مقلب ماء ما يلبس
كالف الاح رداء ماء ما ما ما
ما ما ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء ماء من ردد
في المرعى ماء ما ما ما ماء ما ما ما ما
من ردد في المرع ما ظل الثعلب ماء ما في
مرعاك ماء ما كي يخدعكم ماء ما او يسرق
احد الابناء ماء ماء ماء ماء
ما ما ماء ماء ماء ما ماء ماء ما من ردد
في المرع ما ما ماء ماء ماء ما ماء ماء ما
من ردد في المرع ما لكن عن ذاتي ماء ما
فضحت فعله ماء ما وكشفت ذيله ما ما عاد
يجره بعد عناء ما ما ما ما
[موسيقى]
ما